sur la plateforme spotify parmi les
chansons et les albums un balado
dominent les palmarès
de jogging expérience attirer près de 11
millions d'auditeurs par épisode
mais celui du 31 décembre a été très mal
reçue
l'animateur joe rogan il discute avec le
controversé docteur rythme longue qui
prétend entre autres que les vaccins arn
messagers contre lacko vides sont
néfastes pour les mineurs plus de 200
professionnels de la santé américains
ont dénoncé ce qu'il qualifie de
désinformation
après avoir lancé un ultimatum à spotify
qu'il accuse de propager des théories du
complot la légende du rock no diagne a
retiré ses chansons de la plateforme on
peut imaginer que dans le combat entre
les coudes denis auguin et l'écoutent de
jogging est joe rogan gagne donc il
faisait pas le poids autrement on peut
imaginer que les grecs et le week end 6e
décidé de se retirer de la plate forme e
qui on est disons au moins dix titres
dans le top 100 de chaque année les plus
primés sur spotify on peut imaginer que
le peut-être la réaction toutefois il
serait venu plus rapidement le géant
suédois plutôt que de se dissocier de
joe borg a annoncé des mesures pour
lutter contre la désinformation entre
autres en ajoutant des mises en garde
aux balades au qui évoque la co vide
mais d'autres artistes quittent le
service des côtes en continu dont la
canadienne joni mitchell et le chanteur
et poète québécois gilles vigneault
duisans l'espace sur la question de
spotify c'est une plateforme qui est
incontournable lorsqu'il tire pour la
lisibilité des artistes il faut qu'une
présence sur le numérique mais est ce
que les services et des plateformes sont
en ligne et avec le choix des artistes
c'est l'objet un taux d artistes d'ici
veulent surtout une plus grande vitrine
sur ces plateformes gilles vigneault par
exemple compte vingt-deux mille
auditeurs par mois une fraction de ce
qu'obtiennent le bal à dos le plus
populaire
si neil young fait peut-être pas le
poids contre joe rogan on peut imaginer
les artistes locaux du québec peut-être
le font pas non plus mais d'en joindre
leurs fans à ne pas utiliser le service
ça ça attaque le modèle d'affaires
jewel lui s'excuse et promet de
diversifier les opinions émises à son
émission il sera difficile de lui faire
compétition ici sébastien desrosiers
radio canada